ganz besonders betroffen ist auch
Rheinland-Pfalz neben
Nordrhein-Westfalen und da besonders das
Aartal durch das Ahrtal eigentlich eine
romantische Gegend ist vorgestern eine
riesige Welle hat sich dorthin
durchgewählt und hat verheerende Schäden
angerichtet und gestern gab es ein ganz
bemerkenswertes Ereignis die
Bürgermeisterin der Ortsgemeinde dort im
Ahrtal das ist diese Dame Cornelia
Weigand ist gestern auf die Höhen im
Ahrtal also auf die Höhen gestiegen weil
unten im Tal ja kein Handyempfang mehr
war sie hat ein Interview mit dem
Lokalradio Bonn geführt und hat dann
quasi dramatischen Appell zur Hilfe
abgesetzt der dann auch offenbar gehört
wurde denn es wurden ja Menschen im
Ahrtal via Hubschrauber von ihren
Dächern den Dächern ihre Häuser gerettet
und wir haben dann Cornelia Weigand
gestern besucht und wir haben einen
kamerate dorthin geschickt und Cornelia
Weigand hat uns Ihre Gemeinde gezeigt
und das ist das Ergebnis
wie Sie hier sehen können ist das Wasser
von oben teilweise 40 cm hoch und
Schlammlawinen runtergekommen das gab es
hier noch nie und gleichzeitig ist die
enorm schnell gestiegen und hat ungefähr
die dreifache Höhe gehabt von unserem
Jahrhundert Hochwasser vor fünf Jahren
wir hatten alle Flutwelle die war
wahrscheinlich um die 9 bis 10 Meter
hoch und dementsprechend ist unser Ort
hier in Altenahr völlig zerstört das
heißt auch teilweise das Häuser komplett
weggerissen worden sind Straßen sind
weggerissen worden Ufer Befestigungen
Brücken sind weggerissen worden so dass
unsere komplette Infrastruktur zerstört
ist die Bahngleise sind zum Teil
zerstört die Ortschaften voneinander
sind abgeschnitten weil die Straßen
fehlen
und
die Leute sind hier sehr solidarisch und
wir können das schaffen aber wir können
das nur schaffen wenn wir wirklich Hilfe
bekommen vom Land und vom Bund das ist
alleine sonst nicht stimmbar
viele Menschen in den Orten
mussten sich auf die Hausdächer retten
und die Nacht auf den Dächern verbringen
und heute Morgen nachdem der Nebel Weg
war so ab zehn halb elf sind zum Glück
die Hubschrauber geflogen und etliche
Leute konnten evakuiert werden wir haben
leider schon einige Tote zu verzeichnen
von denen wir wissen
es gibt aber noch viele Menschen die im
Moment in Not sind wo wir nicht wissen
wo sie sind und auch deshalb brauchen
wir Hilfskräfte die uns helfen Leben zu
retten wo noch Leben zu retten ist und
dafür braucht es die katastrophenteams
die sonst eingesetzt werden wenn
woanders auf der Welt Erdbeben passieren
wir versuchen hier mal durchzugehen
also hier sehen dort stand eine große
alte Villa die ist komplett abgerissen
wir wissen nicht
was mit den Menschen ist die dort
wohnten dass der
hier vorne sind die zwei Brücken in die
Tunnel verlaufen die Brücke von unserer
Aartalbahn und unsere Radwegebrücke sind
die beide völlig zerstört sind
hier vorne geht es dann eigentlich der
Tunnel für die Straße durch auf der
anderen Seite des Tunnels gibt es keine
Straße mehr sondern ein fünf Meter
tiefes Loch auf der anderen Seite sieht
das ganz genauso aus aufwärts die
Straßen sind weggespült einige Ortsteile
waren komplett bis über die dachbürste
überflutet wir wissen teilweise noch gar
nicht was mit unseren Menschen ist
und es ist mehr als nur ein Hochwasser
ist es wirklich eine Apokalypse
Leute mit ihnen jetzt gerne mal noch an
die andere Seite des Ortes gehen viel
weiter können wir hier nicht mehr gehen
die sehen wo das Wasser gestanden hat
das können wir auf der anderen Seite
auch noch mal sehr eindringen sehen
wir hatten vor fünf Jahren eine 100
Hochwasser da war der Pegel ungefähr bei
drei Meter 70 jetzt die Welle ist so
hoch gewesen dass sie ungefähr das
Dreifache dieses Jahrhundert
bruchwassers betragen hat wir haben
viele Orte die haben damals kein Wasser
gehabt dort stand jetzt das Wasser bis
in den ersten Stock über die Fenster das
haben Leute ihre Häuser verloren es
haben Leute ihre Angehörigen verloren
dadurch dass wir auch kein Funknetz
haben wissen viele auch nicht was mit
ihren Familien ist die Eltern die in der
Nähe wohnen die Geschwister teilweise
die Eheleute
und die Menschen leben noch in Angst
viele haben unter Todesangst die Nächte
auf Dächern verbracht
und
wir kommen noch nicht mal zu ihnen hin
wir brauchen einfach Unterstützung jetzt
schnellstmöglich nach noch Vermissten zu
suchen auch überhaupt festzustellen Wert
zurzeit vermisst ist ist ganz schwierig
weil aufgrund der fehlenden Funknetze
keine Kommunikation zwischen den Orten
möglich ist
das ist hier mittlerweile schon einiges
an Schlamm aus den Häusern rausgeräumt
wo noch etwas zu räumen war
weiter unten an der Straße war
schlussendlich oder ist kaum noch was zu
machen und unsere ganzen großen Hotels
sind betroffen
wir hatten viele Gäste jetzt nach dem
Corona uns ein bisschen Luft gelassen
hat und insofern hatten die auch viele
Menschen hier in den Häusern wenn hier
die Wassermassen getobt haben
es ist
unbeschreiblich es ist einfach eine
Apokalypse je mehr wir hier uns Richtung
unsere a-brücke nähern desto mehr werden
Sie das sehen wir wissen dass wir
teilweise Orte haben wo es noch noch
schlimmer aussieht
das hier ist eigentlich ein Bereich der
sehr weit über der a liegt
wir sehen auch hier dass das Wasser
3/4 der Eingangstür des Hotels
überflutet hat
und das Jahrhundert Hochwasser ist an
der Stelle gerade mal ungefähr an die
Brücke bekommen
da kann man dann erahnen
mit welcher Wucht sich das ergossen hat
hier stand ein Baugerüst was uns das THW
runter geholt hat weil Einsturzgefahr
bestand
hallo
wenn Sie hier durch gucken auf der
anderen Seite ist der Bahnsteig die
ganze Ufer befestigen das komplett
weggerissen
also hier weitergehen müssen sie relativ
nah bei mir bleiben weil hier Bereiche
der Brücke komplett unterspült sind und
einfach gefährdet
14 gut
Vorsicht
da gab es einen Platz da gab es eine
Uferbefestigung
auf dem Parkplatz dort drüben haben
Autos geparkt ich weiß gar nicht ob wir
ihn jetzt noch sehen wie das schwarze
was dort steht das ist ein ein Reisebus
der dort hinten auf dem Parkplatz stand
und jetzt auf den Gleisen liegt am
Bahnsteig
das Hotel hat die einen großen Parkplatz
davor sie sehen da haben sich die die
Baumstämme gefangen das gleiche ist auf
der Brücke das gleiche ist hier auf der
Seite das gleiche ist dort drüben im
Café alle Cafés Restaurants Hotels sind
dieser beschädigt zerstört
die Existenzen sind weg aber auch unsere
ganze Infrastruktur ist weg die Straßen
sind weg die Brücken sind weg das ist
für uns nicht wieder aufbaubar wenn wir
nicht große finanzielle Unterstützung
kriegen vom Land vom Bund alle unsere
Orte hier an der A an der
Verbandsgemeinde sehen so aus und das
was ich rudimentär mitkriegen konnte im
Prinzip
ist so dass auch von oberhalb Adenau bis
untenvermündung ist ganz genauso
aussieht auch teilweise in den Berglagen
sind die Straßen weggespült und das
schlimme ist das Häuser hier nicht nur
durch unser Spülung zerstört worden sind
sondern das Häuser teilweise
zusammengebrochen sind ganz oder
teilweise eingestürzt sind das Häuser
bis über das Dach überflutet worden sind
und wir oft noch nicht wissen was mit
den Menschen ist
in all diesen Häusern haben die Menschen
teilweise im obersten Stockwerk
teilweise auf dem Dach die Nacht
verbracht
und für viele ist es zum Glück gut
ausgegangen wir wissen aber auch schon
von welchen die wir entweder gefunden
haben oder die wir noch vermissen für
die das aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach
leider nicht gut ausgegangen ist
sie sehen hier in der Straße sind die
Häuser teilweise zusammengebrochen
oft waren die Menschen noch in den
Häusern währenddessen
sie können auch dort hinten sehen wo auf
dem Balkon im ersten Stock die Bäume
liegen auch hier oben ist das das
gleiche mit welcher Wucht und auf
welcher Höhe das Wasser hier
durchgerauscht ist sie sehen hier an dem
grünen Haus noch auf ungefähr
fünf sechs Metern die Linie die a ist
hier eigentlich schon ungefähr
auf Bodenniveau auf ich würde schätzen
drei Meter ich kann es ihnen nicht genau
sagen
eher höher
hier vorne das ist das alte Schulgebäude
und es ist teilweise zusammengebrochen
während die Leute noch oben im Gebäude
waren
und ja es ist einfach es ist
es ist unbeschreiblich es ist nicht
vorstellbar gewesen ein solches
Hochwasser in einer solchen Dimension
hat es nie in der Geschichte dieses
Thales gegeben es gab ein vorheriges
Hochwasser Anfang des 20 Jahrhunderts
vor fast 100 Jahren dort sind damals
alle Brücken an der zerstört worden bis
auf die nepomuk-brücke in rech die ist
jetzt bei diesem Hochwasser auch
zerstört worden
mir fehlen die Worte auf der
Leichenhalle liegen die Baumstämme wir
stand ein Haus das in der größten
flugwelle zusammengebrochen ist
hier vorne liegt ein Auto in der a ich
selber habe wahrscheinlich zwei drei
Dutzend Autos wegtreiben sehen im ganzen
Verlauf werden das noch deutlich mehr
gewesen sein
hier vorne ist ein ein Viadukt und einer
Eisenbahnbrücke die Eisenbahnbrücke hat
es an den Viadukt dran gepresst ist also
auch nicht mehr nutzbar und alles was
noch an Infrastruktur auf unserem
Campingplatz war
ist jetzt Meter dick an dieser
Eisenbrücke aufgestaut
das ist ohne Worte das was man hier
sehen kann ist einfach eine Apokalypse
und ich weiß dass manche unserer Orte
noch viel schlimmer betroffen sind als
hier Altenahr und wir möchten zum einen
Unterstützung haben um die Menschenleben
zu retten die wir noch retten können die
Menschen noch aus der Not zu befreien
die im Moment noch eingeschlossen sind
und wir brauchen
Unterstützung beim Wiederaufbau das hier
ist eine riesige Katastrophe